clocking in at just under two hours free
guy is a breezy often uproarious comedy
action film that plays like the truman
show meets wreck-it ralph but you may
find yourself with some questions by the
time the credits roll so let's explore
what the ending of free guy really means
on the surface guy seems to have earned
himself a happy ending at the end of
free guy his game has not only been
saved but is being drastically rewritten
by keys and millie into a world blending
good-natured open-worlder guys reunited
with buddy his best friend who seemed to
sacrifice himself for the greater good
during the epic dude battle down at the
shore mariah carey is playing his world
seems likely to go on indefinitely and
he helped keys and millie find true love
but is guy truly headed for a happy
ending as buddy drops his weapon belt
one last time to live in a world without
violence it seems highly likely that any
video game allowing online players to
participate via avatar is destined to
encounter some level of hijinks whether
it's more chaining tatum like dudes or
additional bank rubber types who will
inevitably try and throw poor joe
through the window of his store again
for old times sake it seems quite
certain that buddy will someday have to
pick up his weapon again then there's
the matter of guys very essence
constructed to be attracted to millie
finding her every movement comment and
even her favorite ice cream to be
exactly what he longs for in a soulmate
by the end of the movie this has not
changed guy drove millie into the arms
of keys giving the duo their happy
ending but what about mr blue shirt
himself is guy supposed to wander around
for the rest of eternity burdened by the
weight of self-awareness unable to find
the companionship every fiber in his
being was constructed to desire that's
her
who
that's the dream girl buddy it's a
weighty question and one the ending
seems to consider a third rail
far and away the funniest character in
free guy has to be dude a hastily
created muscle-bound rip-off of guy
uploaded to the game in an unfinished
form that has him delivering lines
littered with tbds and punctuated by his
amazing catchphrase catchphrase
after doing his best to kill guy during
their epic fight dude eventually comes
to his senses and joins the good guys in
their effort to expose antoine for the
copyright stealing baddie he truly is in
the film's final moments as all the
heroes find happiness dude can be seen
waving and smiling and seemingly finding
whatever a happy ending looks like in
his half-completed consciousness but
where does dude go from here it doesn't
seem as if millie and keys have plans to
finish dude and make him a whole person
guy seems to tolerate dude as a friend
but as we see in their last interaction
whenever possible he'd much rather cross
the street than hang out with buddy dude
essentially feels like some sort of
puppy enthusiastic protective but able
to interact with other beings on only
the most basic level
for years keys and milli have been
toiling away alongside one another
unable to bridge the awkward gap between
them until free city facilitates key's
desire to profess his undying love by
the end of the film romantic comedy
cliches be damned millie is running
through the streets after her just
revealed soul mate eager to embrace and
live happily ever after but are these
crazy kids destined to marry get a house
in the suburbs with a white picket fence
and have 2.5 children everything we've
seen over the last two hours shows them
to be a very dysfunctional pairing
clearly the two have severe
communication issues spend more time
staring at screens than each other and
have a tendency to connect with people
more easily in virtual environments than
real ones you don't have to be a couples
therapist to see their red flags coming
a mile away
the antagonist of free guy is a spoiled
billionaire brat possessing a serious
sense of entitlement and a god complex
antoine eventually becomes unraveled
desperately slashing away at servers
with an axe in an attempt to destroy
free city and guy before the good guys
can expose him as the copyright stealing
questionably talented figurehead he
really is
then well his character kinda disappears
as guy locates the source code developed
by keys and millie and has the power to
expose their contribution to a worldwide
audience a deal is struck that will
allow them to keep free city and by
extension guy and his friends alive
antoine the film implies can go off and
make sequels which probably won't do
very well without the creative talents
of his developers so can it be assumed
that antoine faced consequences for his
actions depending on how you read into
the existence of the npcs he may have
conceivably killed hundreds of beings
alive in every traditional sense of the
word except the self-awareness granted
by guys ai essentially rendering them
similar to pets and other animals by
taking that axe to all but one of those
servers antoine wiped out hundreds of
npcs even by the most conservative
estimate did antoine face jail time for
his actions highly unlikely since the
copyright theft was buried and we never
see any scenes of police taking him away
it's easy for the free guy movie to
paint a happy ending where million keys
idealistic garden of eden-like new take
on free city is a big hit video game
that everybody loves but in real life
would it be a success
think about that channing tatum cameo as
guy discovers it isn't really the movie
star but some candy scarfing dweeb who
just wants to dance livestream goofy
stuff to his followers and blow things
up oh yeah he also wants to look and
sound like chaining tatum which is why a
guy sees what he sees would that player
want anything to do with the new free
city unlikely in fact based on what we
saw of the old chaotic endlessly violent
free city very few of the old players
would come along for this reimagined
ride instead millie keys and mouser
would have their work cut out for them
as they appeal to an entirely new
audience convincing them that the very
game itself has completely changed it
would be the equivalent of grand theft
auto releasing its newest game tomorrow
and it being like animal crossing loyal
gta enthusiasts would be in an uproar
and good luck enticing that new intended
audience after years of gta
controversies surrounding the game's
violent elements
at the end of the film we see that guy
has become a household name free city
seems to be more popular than ever
before and there are still plenty of
npcs in this next incarnation of the
game so it would seem likely that
million keys will replicate their ai
experiment time and again making more
and more self-aware npc characters with
their breakthrough technology but would
this be a good thing would gamers really
want to play a game where every single
background character thought they were
the main character on the other hand
isn't that life if every npc thought
they were the main character could you
imagine how hard it would be to give a
game any sort of plot missions or
overall goal perhaps you could measure
success in the game the same way some
measure success in real life money
accumulated job title achieved etc but
honestly at that point it would probably
just be better to turn off the game say
goodbye to guy once and for all go
outside and enjoy the real world life in
the big city ain't nothing like it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite summer blockbusters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]